let's go next to nick
from st louis missouri you're on the air
hi david uh
my question for you is uh so with the
2022 midterms coming up
i just would think it'd be a no-brainer
for biden to take some sort of stance on
uh decriminalizing marijuana
on like the federal level yeah uh i just
think that'd be an easy layup for
democrats to
you know make a comeback since the tail
like everyone's saying that they're
going to get slaughtered in the 2022 uh
midterm so what's your opinion on that i
completely agree this sort of came up a
little bit on the show last uh last week
i think that um it would be an easy
obvious net positive for biden to push
decriminalization
um there are a couple different
perspectives on how it could be done
could it be done by executive order
could it be done by simply directing the
dea
to sort of make it happen there are some
who say he can't do it although i've not
found those legal arguments compelling
as a layperson but yeah i completely
agree there there are people who would
be mad at biden decriminalizing cannabis
but it would be an obvious net positive
and i think he has very little interest
in actually trying to make it happen
do you think his reluctance to not try
to make anything happen on that front is
because of his own personal
or religious beliefs no i don't think so
i mean it's sort of like with the
student loan thing right where people
are saying why isn't he forgiving
student loan debt like i never thought
he cared about student loan debt and i
think at one point he said he would do
10 grand and people were saying 50. at
no point did i believe he really cared
about it i don't think it's religious i
don't think it's personal i think
there's just certain issues he doesn't
care about and he sort of talked about
them because he was running a campaign
and people imposed these issues on him i
just don't think he cares it's i wish i
had something deeper but i think it's
it's that simple
but i mean going to student loans but
given that his wife is a teacher yeah
you would think that that would have
some sort of impact and hit you know the
priorities i agree especially because
it's so popular um those two issues on
on the left marijuana maybe more you
know everyone but uh
i just i don't see why
no action or no even updates even
avoiding questions and briefings about
those issues i agree with you 100
and you know there's two sides on this
one is he's just being advised
incorrectly the other one would be there
are downsides you and i aren't thinking
of and that's why he's staying away from
these issues it's probably a mix of both
okay well thanks for answering my
question david all right my pleasure uh
great to hear from you